you
so I think the linear regression output
in R is really informative but if you
don't understand what you're looking at
it can be pretty overwhelming and
confusing so in this video I just wanted
to give a quick explanation of each
component of the regression summary and
assuming your model is good tell you
what type of values you should be
expecting you may be taking an
introductory statistics course before
but I'll also briefly touch on some
basic topics throughout the video just
to hopefully give you a better
understanding of how this output can be
useful so I found this fish market data
set online and if we go ahead and open
this up you can see that there are four
columns the species the weight the
height and the width and in this video
we're gonna make a linear model to
predict the weight based on the height
and the width but I want to preface this
by saying I would probably include the
species as a categorical variable but
we're gonna leave it out just to keep it
more simple and the other thing is that
there's likely correlation between the
height and the width which will make our
estimates kind of weird but I'll touch
on that later so once we have that data
set red in we're gonna create our linear
model and then we're going to view our
linear model output so the first element
of the output is the call and this is
pretty straightforward the LM tells us
that this is a linear model and then on
the left of the tilde is the weight
which is our Y variable or the response
variable on the right of the tilde are
our X variables or explanatory variables
so we have the height and the width and
then you might also see some other
arguments like for instance the data
frame that the model is using next are
the residuals now the residuals are the
difference between the observed and
predicted values so we've got the min
which represents the data point furthest
below the regression line the first
quartile so 25% of the residuals are
less than this number the median the
third quartile where 25% of the
residuals are greater than this number
and the max or the point that's furthest
above the regression line we don't see
the mean on here because with linear
regressions the mean will actually
always be zero since that's what they
optimized for but starting with the
median we want this number to be as
close to zero as possible now I should
preface that it's hard to define exactly
what's close to zero or far from zero
because it's relative to your data so
you'll need to use your intuition when
comes to interpreting these numbers
anyway we want the median to be close to
zero our mean because it would imply
that the model isn't skewed one way or
another
another condition of a good linear
regression is that the residuals should
be symmetrically distributed so we want
our min and Max to have the same
magnitude and we want our first quartile
and third quartile numbers to also have
around the same magnitude you can see in
this case the first quartile and third
quartile are kind of close but the min
and Max are really different so we're
definitely looking at some problems here
so just to review in this example assume
that the blue points are our actual data
points that the red line is the
regression line and that the green line
are the residuals or the difference
between the actual value and the
predicted value so the residual is going
to be positive if the actual data point
is above the regression line and
negative if the actual data point is
below the regression line and it looks
like these two points are going to be
our min residual because it's the point
that's furthest below the red line and
this is going to be our max because it's
the point that's farthest above the red
line and then in this example we would
expect the regression line to follow the
data points but you can see that it's
not because there's this one leveraged
outlier in the bottom right that's
pulling down our whole line so if we
look at the output of this regression
the median residual might actually be
close to 0 but the min and Max would be
huge however if we remove the outlier
and refit the regression you can now see
that the line follows the data a lot
better and here the median residual
would still be close to 0 but the min
and Max would be much much smaller
giving us more confidence in our fit so
the residuals in the regression output
can actually tell us a decent amount
about the fit of the line without even
having to view a plot so next are the
coefficients starting with the names and
you can see by default the intercept
will always be included and you can also
see any X variables included in the
model so we have height and width then
there are the estimates which you'd use
for predicting your response variable
the way that you'd quickly interpret the
estimate for the height for instance is
a one centimeter increase in height will
result in a 4 point 8 to 5 increase in
grams of the weight
ideally you want these numbers to make
sense like for instance I think that is
the height and width increase the weight
should also increase so these numbers
should be positive and luckily they are
but sometimes if you're doing a multiple
linear regression and there's
multicollinearity or in other words the
X variables are not independent then the
estimates might be drastically different
from what you expected and the
interpretation might not make much sense
standard error is the average amount
that the estimate varies from the actual
value so ideally you want a lower number
relative to the coefficients and you can
use this number to calculate a
confidence interval of your estimate the
T value is a measure of how many
standard deviations there are between
the estimate and zero so it's literally
the estimate divided by the standard
error in general if the T value has a
really high magnitude the coefficient is
going to be statistically significant
and that brings us to the last column
which is PR is greater than the absolute
value of T which gives us a p-value for
the T test if the number is small and we
typically use point O five of benchmark
it means that it's unlikely that the
relationship between the Y variable and
one of the coefficients was due to
chance there are these stars or periods
next to your estimates and these
represent the significance so there's a
key down here showing significance codes
where more stars implies more
significance so imagine we plotted one
of our estimates on a graph either the
intercept or one of the slopes and it's
important to remember that this is just
an estimate but not the actual number
and that's why we have a distribution
around this estimate because we don't
know what the actual number is but we
are fairly sure 95% sure that it lies
within this confidence interval and how
do we calculate this confidence interval
well we take the estimate and subtract
about two times the standard error to
get the lower bound and add about two
times the standard error to get the
upper bound we also might be wondering
what does it mean for this estimate to
be statistically significant well our
null hypothesis was that this variable
has no effect on the dependent variable
or in other words this estimate should
be about zero but if our confidence
interval is really far from zero like in
this situation
that's going to give us a low p-value
for a t-test implying that this effect
is actually nonzero and is statistically
significant the residual standard error
provides us a measure of how much the
actual value will differ from the value
we're trying to predict or in other
words the standard error of the
residuals the degrees of freedom are the
number of data points that went into the
estimation of the parameter so this is
typically the rows of the data minus the
number of variables that were estimating
and that includes the intercept so in
this situation our fish data frame has
159 entries or 159 rows and we're
estimating three different values so 159
minus 3 gives us us 156 degrees of
freedom next is the R squared which I
bet most people are familiar with but
essentially it gives you a measurement
of what percent of the variance in the
response variable can be explained by
the regression so this is an image I
found online and the example is showing
how temperature affects the amount of
money that a lemonade stand generates
it's a little tough to read but on the
x-axis we have temperature and on the
y-axis we have revenue so on the graph
we see that the regression line fits
pretty closely with the data points and
that the r-squared is point a 1 which
means 81 percent of the variation in
revenue can be explained by the
temperature now in this other graph
which is of a different lemonade stand
the r-squared is obviously a lot smaller
which makes sense because the
temperature doesn't seem to be the best
predictor and it could be that this
lemonade stand is actually indoors so
the outside temperature doesn't really
have a huge effect on revenue now we see
that there are two types of R Squared's
the multiple R squared and the adjusted
R squared the multiple R squared will
show you the amount of variation in the
response variable explained by the
predictor variables like I mentioned
before and if you were to keep adding
more predictor variables the R squared
would essentially always increase
because predictors will always explain
some portion of the variance but this
doesn't necessarily mean the model is
getting better it could just be that
you're overfitting to your data now the
adjusted R squared on the other hand
controls against this increase and it
adds penalties each time you add another
predictor to the model so this
distinction doesn't matter too much
innocent
linear regression where you only have
one intercept and one slope but it makes
more sense in multiple linear regression
where you might have multiple predictors
essentially you want your model to be
parsimonious or somewhat simple but also
fit the data really well and if there's
a large enough difference between your
multiple r-squared and your adjusted
r-squared you may have over fit your
model so last is the F statistic which
is a general indicator of whether
there's actually a relationship between
the predictor variables and your
response variable so a number further
from one is actually better but again
you can pay attention to the p-value on
the side to determine if the model as a
whole is statistically significant and
in this case because this number is much
smaller than 0.05 this model as a whole
is statistically significant so that
pretty much covers the linear regression
output and our but I'll be doing another
video soon about the different
regression plots and how to diagnose
your linear model but anyway if you
found this video helpful I'd appreciate
if you liked the video and definitely
subscribe if you're interested in this
type of content anyway thanks for
watching and I'll catch you in the next
one